[Aplausos]
não tem chefe de horários flexíveis e
ser feliz fazendo o que ama esse é o
tripé de sucesso só que não perceberam
que é isso que a gente costuma ouvir nos
grandes eventos de empreendedorismo
só quando entrei nessa área de
empreendedorismo ninguém nunca me falou
que empreendesse vir a se virar para
fazer algo artesanalmente por que você
gosta e sabe trabalhar mais de 18 20
horas por dia por isso isso aqui não tem
tempo para nada nem para a vida pessoal
e por aí vai
e uma das coisas e é tão comum também
talvez nesses grandes eventos ea cômodo
acho que a palavra certa é comum e fácil
para quem tem um negócio pra quem tem
pra que coordena a alguma organização
começar a falar da sua da sua ideia das
grandes idéias como ensinado o que é o
que faz e os resultados alcançados in e
também muito cômodo para a gente que
está ouvindo pegar aquela ideia e aquele
tripé do sucesso e achar que nossa idéia
é tão boa quanto porque uma pessoa
falando nessa crise
e pra que vocês entendam melhor o que
estou tentando dizer vou trazer alguns
casos estava num evento em salvador o
menino de engenho 21 então quase na
idade de 24 anos começou a trazer essa
ideia está a aps e tudo mais trazendo
como iniciou e os resultados alcançados
e como ele iniciou e pedir emprestado
investimento de 30 mil reais a seu pai e
conseguiu triplicar esse valor em um ano
foi em nós
eu que não vou conseguir fazer isso
só que ele esqueceu que 56% dos
empreendedores negros no brasil
começaram
antes dos 18 anos e trabalho infantil
e nem por isso a gente é um empreendedor
de sucesso teve um outro que trabalhou
mais de 30 anos em grandes empresas do
estado da bahia e resolveu de repente
nem sempre só trabalha há 30 anos e um
consegue um património a resolve prender
e largou tudo para empreender né ea dica
dele foi seja inovador né criatividade
mas seja criativo
esse tema e sistematize tudo coloco tudo
no papel
mas ele também esqueceu que mais da
metade dos afro empreendedores hoje não
tem nenhum tipo de instrução 11 por
cento conseguiram chegar o ensino
fundamental e apenas 4%
está fluindo ensino superior claro que
pode ter mudado esses dados que é do
sebrae
donos de negócios no brasil por conta de
ações afirmativas mas não significa que
está diferente hoje
e uma última ela vira pra toda a platéia
e fala
vocês não são ricas porque não querem
aí eu parei a ser feito no lugar errado
né gente
é só ter um negócio chamado reserva
financeira só colocar na poupança
tesouro reserva financeira encontrar o
propósito o propósito se encontra com
treino o propósito e você consegue ser
feliz fazendo o que ama por isso é um
mito de ser feliz fazendo o que falei
gente totalmente no lugar errado né
uma pessoa tem coragem de olhar para uma
outra pronta até na verdade como essa
olhando pra vocês
ignorar que 62% dos afro-brasileiros
sustentam a casa e desses 22 são casados
ou casadas de 17% têm filhos ou seja não
dá para abandonar é o único sustento nós
sendo que a gente ganha até mil reais
trabalhando como ambulante trabalhando
como manicure gente não pensa que eu sou
mercenário não tá isso é só para mostrar
o que a gente chama hoje de
empreendedorismo
nós mulheres negras a periferia sempre
chamou de sobrevivência é tudo é tudo
renda complementar e falar de dinheiro
falar sobre isso não significa que a
gente está ignorando que o racismo é a
manutenção do capitalismo não significa
falar sobre isso é para mostrar que
preto dinheiro não são palavras e mais
mulher preta poder também não são todos
iguais falar sobre isso é mostrar que
não queremos mais ser apenas
beneficiários da política
queremos sentar na mesa e também decide
o rumo das coisas
e pra vocês não ficarem tristes assim
com esses dados têm ideias excelentes de
notórios anônimos que estão pelo mundo
que merece ser compartilhadas e um
exemplo é uma feira que leva o nome de
preta preto que é mais do que exposição
de produtos e serviços é mais que um
show é mais do que isso estamos falando
de autonomia econômica e financeira para
a comunidade negra
o outro é um desabafo que saiu do
pessoal e social
e quando afirma se a coisa tá preta
coisa boa não é só estampa de camiseta
não é só uma palestra nesta uma
simplicidade que estava realizando nas
redes sociais
estamos falando de autoestima sem
esquecer do quilombo primeiro aplicativo
e único no mundo feito por pessoas
negras para pessoas negras anunciarem
seus serviços e por fim a kumasi que é o
primeiro marketplace para empreendedores
negros de salvador inicialmente por quê
e é a maior capital negra do país que
entendeu que preto dinheiro são palavras
rivais e mais do que o marketplace virou
um suporte para empreendedores negros na
área de marketing gestão e negócio
incrível né
pode falar em que liga mas quero falar
outra coisa
não sei se vocês perceberam que é uma
pessoa que nos alegra de certa forma
quando a gente sai de casa do trabalho
trabalho para a faculdade escola e tudo
mais que convence a gente a comprar um
produto tinha um sorriso nosso tudo isso
em menos de um minuto
estou falando dos vendedores de balas e
doces nos transportes públicos que
também são os maiores empreendedores não
foi nesses eventos de empreendedorismo
que eles aprenderam o que chamamos de
pitty de elevador não é não foi com
certeza não foi e só reforça o que eu
falei no início sobrevivência eo melhor
de tudo é que as mulheres incríveis que
subiram nesse palco e as outras que
subiram nesse palco ainda hoje está
petit vermelho de ançã quem tem ideias
tão incríveis inspiradoras quanto da
feira preta do quilombo da bug naipe e
por aí vai
só que fosse eu fosse pra deixar uma
dica menina novinha 21 anos uma dica é
nunca compareceu início com medo de
ninguém
é todo um processo e obrigada
[Aplausos]